this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman something
caught my eye on Twitter today I'd like
to address with you in front of everyone
if you know what was it that tweet from
Carlos basket no it wasn't caught my
[ __ ] eye - it's about you and you're
curious choices in advertising Kevin
will brand anything kevin is a human
walking brand and today on Twitter
you posted a picture don't take the joy
out of this for me man of your day at
the dentist this happened today no it
happened well I mean it's a multi-part
procedure because I had a bridge that I
had to get replaced because they put it
in back when I was working on cop-out
and apparently the Pontic the the tooth
that went in the bridge hole right was
like double the size it was supposed to
be so these cats were like let us give
you a real one so they redid this I'm
sorry importantly wrong said they redid
this bridge and so while the bridge was
well the bridge was off
why this is a cool thing I like this
don't piss on this man I just think it's
weird my dentist is a really [ __ ]
good guy man John Moore ah she's totally
he's a skateboarder [ __ ] like Daisy a
stoner cuz it seems like a stoner move
[Laughter]
he had shown me like somebody was did
something similar mind I got like a
tooth implant or tooth or something and
on the inside of the tooth that he had
done the Bones Brigade sign because he
was a skateboarder that looked really
cool so it's just like look I'm gonna um
you're getting a bridge do you want
anything written on the back of your
teeth uh-huh and I was just like [ __ ]
yes like nobody's ever asked me that
before you know why because it's a
[ __ ] idea I'm Jun their [ __ ]
teeth I've had dudes be like let me
paint the inside of your mouth but I've
never had some dude be like let me write
on the inside here teeth so I said [ __ ]
yeah I see you do it while it's in my
mouth and goes no I do it while it's all
made it and then I stick it in your
mouth I said well
I simple anybody see it he goes only if
you want them to and I was like you know
what man [ __ ] you only live once so I
was like what would I want there and I
thought about like a zillion [ __ ] job
one point I thought about putting tusks
because because the movies coming but
then I was like that seems temporary and
what if like a year from now I'm like I
hate tusks yeah then I thought about
going funny and put like [ __ ] like
insert [ __ ] here yeah but nobody would
rarely see that joke except my wife and
she wouldn't think it was funny right so
I went with like the thing that means
the most to me and I think we have make
sure that can we throw out the picture
of what's inside Kevin's mouth now
[Applause]
Smaug it's ridiculous this kind of dopey
it didn't cost me an extra [ __ ] penny
or anything but Oh as well as long as
it's free why not make it ask yourself
right totally but I was just like I
don't know I'm 43 like this is something
I would ask my mother and father do when
I was a kid they already were [ __ ]
mine and rightly so but but honestly it
comes down to this like when I was in
Australia a couple of years ago I got a
tattoo on my arm says in sma'da I trust
right there it's in my handwriting I
wrote down a piece of paper and they
kind of put it over my hand and then
tattooed it in and stuff right so in
smut I trust is very simple like I grew
up [ __ ] Catholic man and I was always
told like God God God does everything
for you God trust in God and I you know
you get to a certain point in life where
you're like I'm [ __ ] middle-aged man
I don't think there's an invisible
person this guy plotting my existence I
think I might have something to do with
it
so so I not paint my teeth there was a
god that wouldn't have happened
no the end smart I trust is meant to
[ __ ] represent like in me like trust
in me I've gotten myself [ __ ] this
far and stuff so never mind giving it up
to some [ __ ] invisible person like
trust in himself
you know yourself there so that when I
when I chose smart it wasn't like
branding for the podcast it's just I
don't know I've been on this journey but
this whole SModcast thing and it's gone
in weird wonderful directions we have a
podcast we've been doing for years which
is now gonna be a TV show there's a
movie that came off the podcast like
comic book man came off SModcast
eventually so everything
eyes back to that moment a few years ago
and I was like let me start doing a
podcast so I just wanted to celebrate it
in my teeth sure like one does so I just
put it in there it's a little [ __ ]
gangsta I know but still oh yeah you're
og totally you don't have to be afraid
of me I'm totally cool to be around
instead but in any event please don't
make fun of it well it's a little late
for that now it really is anyway let's
[ __ ] talk about something else
penises no one's ever going to see that
thing inside your mouth
fair enough fair enough you'll get it
you'll be able to find out if I ever
have sucked a dick all I have to do is
look at the dick and see if there's an
impression of smart in the head
backwards proof let the role the penis
in ink and see the prints out smile cuz
it'll be back where it's a good idea
imma sell those on the website yeah
[Music]